♪♪♪
- Let the MVP race begin!
- You don't blow me!
- This thing honestly drives itself.
- Yo, what up, fam? I'm mad fun to watch.
- Mind if I party barge in?
- Receivers can't win anyway!
- This is straight-up just a cliff.
- Guardrail, Mike!
- You gotta cut me out of the narrative!
Position players will never win MVP!
- Huh?
- Let’s go quarterbacks!
- We support YOU.
- Get in, J.T.
- Hey, Carson, want me to drive for you like normal?
- Take the blue ball and continue living in the QB-friendly league.
But take the red ball—
- Oh, dang, he took them both.
- [Derrick Henry:] So many carries…he IS the one.
See, nine years ago, the QBs rose up and ensured that only they would win MVP.
These people are trapped in delusions.
- Not gonna lie, I’m barely following.
- Never send a man to do a machine’s job.
- Whoa, they recast Agent Brady?
- That's so weird!
- They took Henry out!
- I used to be like them...
But then they made me an MVP candidate, and I knew it was all fake.
- That's it...I know the secret.
No one is really playing well this year.
- So the first half of the season just, like, doesn't matter?
- Yeah, you can always just come back.
- People LOVE sequels.
- Any weapons?
- I AM a weapon!
AHHHHHH!
STOP SCRAMBLING AND TAKE A SACK.
- Take me higher than I’ve ever been.
- BOOM.
- Yo, sup, fam?
- We took it to slo-mo yet again to show you—
OH, J,T, KNOWS HE'S IN SLOW-MO!
- Oh, damn.
- I see the holes in the Matrix now.
- Of course THEY would never let me win.
- I got it!
- Nah, I'm taking us to the volcano.
[Coughing]